Adam you moved back to New York not long
ago how do you like living in New York I
love it Conan
I really am have I thought y'all from
there I was born there and so I thought
when I when I got back it would be like
more of a warmer reception like
everywhere on the streets people would
be like hey the prodigal son returns but
in actuality it's more like you know we
don't have that name for a reservation
sir
yeah well it's a pretty big city and for
them to like notice you're gone is a lot
to probably ask yeah the city leaves the
city leaves and breeds without you I
noticed that when I left
and also I walk around like this all the
time so maybe are you okay right now you
I can't tell if you're slowly dying or
if you're uncomfortable I'm actually in
this suit you aged backwards this is
like Russell Simmons is opening a gym
where you go I'm also noticing he said
Russell Simmons you made Richard Simmons
no I meant you know I met Russell you
did yeah Richard did no one has seen in
two years like I feel like this this
Batman is dealing with the death of his
parents in a way for other than just
birthday
he both has taken up crime fighting and
yeah it's constantly the only people
that refer to him
this Batman is a vigilante are the
breadsticks at Olive Garden
how's the paparazzi in New York that
must be tricky to open you can act like
it's a regular show Conan okay by the
way yeah Jeff
well you know this I'm gonna tell him
something that we're doing a movie
together that's right we buddy whoa
we're playing the same character
I'm obviously older him he's younger me
or filming at this summer yeah cool no
I'm so I'm getting in shape for it this
part right here is just so secondly you
know what I call this white my Jonah
Hill I'm dealing with that what do you
think Jonah's gonna come after
[Laughter]
you